lung cancer is the leading cause of
cancer deaths in Malaysia for both men
and women your lungs are too spongy
organs in your chest the left lung is
divided into two lobes or sections and
the right lung has three lobes when you
breathe in air enters your nose or mouth
and passes into your trachea or windpipe
at the Carina the trachea divides into
two bronchi then branches into smaller
bronchioles the bronchioles end in tiny
air sacs or alveoli here the oxygen in
the air you inhale passes into the
bloodstream and carbon dioxide from your
body passes out of the bloodstream the
carbon dioxide is expelled from your
body when you exhale your lungs are
encased by pleura a thin membrane that
protects them and helps them slide back
and forth as you breathe in and out
underneath your lungs is the diaphragm a
smooth thin muscle that helps your lungs
expand and contract as you breathe your
lungs are connected to small collections
of immune system cells called lymph
nodes by way of lymphatic vessels you
have groups of these lymph nodes near
your lungs above your collarbones and
behind your breastbone as well as in
other parts of your body the lymphatic
vessels carry bacteria cancer cells and
other unhealthy material away from your
lungs and other organs in a clear fluid
called lymph lymph nodes filter this
material out of the lymph lung cancers
most commonly start in the bronchi but
they can also begin in the trachea
bronchioles or alveoli